[Music]
imagine you're an investigation officer
and you need to find the criminal in the
case assigned to you you are given
samples of blood obtained from the crime
scene and have three suspects on the
list how will you find out which suspect
is the criminal and the case doesn't end
here
simultaneously you have to hand over the
little kid of the victim to one of the
two men claiming to be the child's
father how will you solve both the
mysteries together there is one solution
for both the problems and it's called
DNA fingerprinting this technique is
very crucial in terms of advancement in
modern science and technology it's a
technique that helps us analyze our
unique DNA just like the unique
fingerprints that we have the profiles
at the end help us analyze the DNA of
every individual for instance looking at
the results of the first part we can
almost be sure that suspect 2 is the
criminal and similarly in the second
part we can say that individual 1 is the
biological father of the child does
every person really have a unique DNA of
course DNA is termed as the blueprint of
life it's a specific set of instructions
that gives rise to the characters that's
seen in the organisms but this is
something that we're aware of today and
it wasn't known back then so who
discovered that DNA is so important
which scientists or scientists
contributed towards finding out that DNA
is the code for all the characteristics
in us let's find that out by going back
in time firstly let's have a look at the
milestones in this journey to begin with
we have the father of genetics Gregor
Mendel who introduced the concept of
heredity to us he was the first to
hypothesize that there are factors
which passed from parents to offspring
this was around mid 1860s however his
work was largely ignored it was around
the first decade of the 20th century
that the two scientists came up with the
theory which helped prove Mendelian
genetics who were the two scientists
they were Walter Sutton and Theodor
Boveri they put forth the chromosomal
theory of inheritance which helped shine
some light on the long ignored work of
Gregor Mendel however Sutton and
bovary's work gained better acceptance
with the next milestone which was
achieved by the father of experimental
genetics Thomas Morgan Morgan's work on
the little fruit fly was very
instrumental in proving the fact that
genes are located on the chromosomes his
experiments helped explain the location
of eye color genes on the X chromosomes
in Drosophila melanogaster we have seen
the history of genetics until this time
now it's time we move a step ahead in
the timeline until this time scientists
believed that genes which are the units
of heredity are majorly made up of
proteins in other words the chemical
nature of the genetic material was
thought to be proteins however this
wasn't really considered to be a fact it
was just an assumption people were still
trying to figure out what exactly could
the genetic material be made up of it
was around 1928 that a breakthrough was
achieved in this field a British
bacteriologist named Frederick Griffith
reported for the first time that tiny
organisms like the bacteria are also
capable of transferring genetic
information
his famous transformation experiment
ignited the curiosity regarding genetic
material a few years later around 1944
three scientists named Avery MacLeod and
McCarty figured out that the
transforming principle or the unit of
heredity to be
is actually DNA and this was strongly
supported by the work of Hershey and
chase later around the Year in 1952 the
simple experiment by these two helped
prove that it's DNA and not the proteins
that form the core of the genetic
material later the structure of the DNA
built by the efforts of Franklin Watson
and Crick
formed a strong foundation for
modern-day genetics this timeline helps
us with the milestones achieved so far
in genetics let's have a detailed look
at each of these experiments and events
in the upcoming parts
[Music]